is it really surprising that these these
alpha cuck
tucker
anti-mass types are french frying their
nut sacs is it really that surprising it
shouldn't be that surprising that this
is what they're doing now as uh everyone
knows uh
testicular testy testy tanning is
trending on
uh twitter this morning
and the reason why is because of this
clip right here let me let me make this
a little bigger so you can see um
this may or may not be the doctor that
just came on that was has the degree
from herverd university down in alabama
where he
graduated summa [ __ ] laude but let's
let's listen to what him and tucker
carlson talk about french frying french
frying your balsack let's listen you saw
in the clip there
if you want to optimize and take it
to another level expose yourself to red
light therapy yes and the juve
that we were using in the documentary he
said the juve
since then that's the vernacular i guess
i don't know
there's a massive amount of testicle
tanning testicle tanning which is
testicle tanning like literally when you
say it out loud
tucker
you said it out loud here's the putin
propaganda network
right
abandoning their putin propaganda
to talk about how men aren't manly
i'm gonna break down what the [ __ ] that
means and what they're trying to say in
the tropes they're trying to say but
more importantly what fox news and
tucker carlson are trying to do here
ultimately to their audience testicle
tanning but it's also full body uh red
light therapy which has massive amount
of benefits and there's so much data out
there um there's so much data out there
on the internet you know you just put it
up on the internet and then it's there
that doesn't mean i think you want to
cover so obviously half the viewers
right now are like what that's quite
contained that's crazy no not half the
viewers all of them
all of them but the ones that are
already tanning their testicles
are going what in the [ __ ] are you
talking about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
tanning your testicles now here's the
thing
a lot of [ __ ] idiots watch this show
and we're like testicle tanning that
makes you more manly well let's let's
tan them up bros
just christ but my view is okay
testosterone levels crash and nobody
says anything about it that's crazy
testosterone level levels are not
crashing that is such [ __ ] stupid-ass
[ __ ]
that's such stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] now
an army our argument could be made that
testosterone levels are lower now for a
lot of different reasons but they're not
crashing this is really dumb
and this is really [ __ ] stupid to
think that your testosterone levels are
the thing that make you manly tucker
carlson and these [ __ ] alpha cup
types are [ __ ] stupid
your testosterone levels and how much
you can lift at the gym has nothing to
do with you being manly
go ask anyone who knows anything about
being attracted to a manly man okay
it has nothing to do with it not a god
damn thing
this is all a [ __ ] trope of gay men
can't be manly and manly men can't be
gay if you're insecure about your
sexuality and your homosexual tendencies
out there this is tucker carlson
speaking to his listeners
if you are insecure about your sexuality
and your homosexual tendencies my
audience have no fear
because if you're a manly man and you
tan your balls
then you must not be gay so don't listen
to those little whispers inside your
head
this is all really [ __ ] stupid this
is the same nonsense and the same
dribble where [ __ ] men get their
[ __ ] butt hurt because a trans woman
goes into a bathroom to take a leak
they're so [ __ ] obsessed obsessed
with genitalia it's [ __ ] weird and
gross
but the reason why is it's because
of their insecurities there and they're
terrified of sexuality
terrified of sexuality
but it's because of their insecurities
of their homosexual tendencies here's
what i'm talking about you want to know
what i'm talking about dude goes to a
gym
sees a bunch of other dudes lifting
weights
sweaty muscular really pumping the iron
right
oh man i want to look like him he's sexy
deep down inside he says
that must be that must be a homosexual
tendency so they get a little frightened
right they get frightened because
they're terrified of sexuality the other
thing is they're terrified of someone
knowing that they might find a dude sexy
my god his body's sexy
and that makes them gay and the only way
to not be gay is to have more
testosterone
it's all a [ __ ] trope the whole
[ __ ] show the whole [ __ ] thing
it's a trope that if you're a manly man
you can't be gay
and if you're gay you can't be a manly
man it's really [ __ ] dumb
it's really [ __ ] dumb because here's
the here's the bottom line
the tucker carlson tucker carlson
couldn't handle a manly man he couldn't
because he's a little whiny [ __ ]
tucker carlson is and all this is is
more [ __ ] disputed their audience to
do the whole tucker carlson's trying out
joe rogan joe rogan here
to make it to where non-experts who
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about who have no idea what they're
saying
and don't give a [ __ ] about actual
studying actual science to try to prove
something is or isn't true
to just spew their garbage and make them
into experts just like joe rogan does on
his show
it's the same [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
anti-bass anti-mask anti-backs type [ __ ]
same [ __ ] same [ __ ]
oh you get well [ __ ] if you just
exercise then you'll you'll fend off
disease well being healthy
helps if you get a disease but being
healthy doesn't prevent you from getting
a disease you dumb [ __ ]
being healthy doesn't prevent your
testosterone levels from dropping
there's a whole hell of a host of
reasons why a dude's testosterone levels
would drop
and the best solution
i'm not a doctor
i'm not but i would go seek advice to a
doctor who knows something about
testosterone before you start french
frying your nut sac
and really honestly i bet the doctor's
gonna prescribe you i don't know if you
have low t testosterone
it really is [ __ ] dumb
but the point of all this this whole
documentary all this [ __ ]
is just
just an anti-gay trope that if you're
gay you're not manly and trust me manly
men out there
don't just ignore your homosexual
tendencies because if you're manly
you must not be gay
really is
more than trudging out
of their anti-lgbtq
agenda
i hate gay people
i don't want gay people
and they're terrified
terrified
of their own homosexual tendencies
terrified of them
can't get past them